j'ai 23 ans je suis
là est en mission
je suis griévement blessé allongé sur
mon lit d'hôpital
l'infirmière à côté de moi me dit vous a
eu le bras gauche arrachée au niveau du
coude et on vous a coupé au quart
supérieur pour éviter l'infection moi
sur mon lit je ne sens rien fait parce
qu'en fait je suis allongé et je n'ai
pas encore la vision de mon bras qui
nous manque et en fait quand vous avez
une amputation de membres vous avez ce
qu'on appelle le membre fantôme un
membre qui existe dans votre schéma
corporel et schémas au niveau du cerveau
mais qui n'existe plus physiquement et
en fait je me dis ah ah oui
effectivement
et c'est le choc il ya un truc qui me
vient à la tête
un truc de dingue c'est comment je vais
faire avec les filles je me dis un
hommage correspondent plus aux moules
j'ai un bras est ce que les filles
vaudront de moi c'est pas facile
23 ans et en fait je m'aperçois que la
vie en fait elle n'est pas fait comme ça
et que les liens entre les gens mais ça
marche pas comme ça
et en fait ça m'arrange et effectivement
ça s'est arrangé dans ma vie plus tard
être une personne handicapée c'est un
parcours et un parcours alors je dis
souvent qu'il ya trois étapes
il ya le deuil l'état de la
reconstruction est l'étape de la
résilience le deuil ça permet justement
de de faire une acceptation de son
handicap est alors moi j'ai eu la chance
en fait j'ai un caractère positif et
j'ai eu la chance cette partie là a été
assez rapide
au bout de deux mois j'ai j'ai très bien
accepté mon handicap
et puis et puis ensuite je suis passé à
la période de reconstruction n'est pas
reconstruction a été a été assez assez
longue
parce que ça permet de se réparer se
soigne et éventuellement d'apprendre
avec une prothèse avoir l'ergothérapie
donc voilà c'est une période que on se
donne à nous mêmes nos mois elle a duré
à peu près un an et ensuite vous avez
cette perte de résilience cette paire de
région c'est ce que je fais aujourd'hui
avec vous c'est parler de son handicap
avoir un peu de recul sur le sujet et
donc ça permet ça permet de d'être
tranquille sur son handicap
alors ensuite je vais vous expliquer
comment comment on fait pour reconnaître
la différence entre une personne valide
et une personne handicapée c'est simple
le matin vous vous préparez vous êtes
une personne valide vous habillez vous
prenez votre sac vous et au travail vous
rené le soir vous posez votre sac et
vous occupez votre famille en fait la
personne et gap et c'est presque pareil
le matin et se prépare elle à son sac
elle fait sa journée de travail
et quand elle rentre elle elle ne pose
pas le sac en fait ce axé son handicap
elle a toute sa vie
aujourd'hui j'ai 49 ans je suis marié
j'ai deux filles et je suis hyper
content de ma vie je suis heureux je
j'aime ce que j'ai fait de ma vie et
j'aime ce que je vais en faire à plus
tard voyez par exemple
là je vais au delà je vais avoir besoin
de vous moi ma blague préférée c'est ce
que c'est c'est pas de bras
yes j'adore cette blague j'adore ses
blagues mes collègues me laffont les
amis me laffont j'adore cette blague un
jour ma une de mes filles
elle me dit mais papa a était petite et
elle le dit mais papa je comprends pas à
bras pas de chocolat tata it reste un
bras tu as droit la moitié des
plaquettes
alors là je peux vous dire le
soulagement
en plus j'adore le chocolat donc alors
je peux vous dire que là le soulagement
c'est la classe merci ma fille mercy
mes enfants m'ont toujours connu mes
enfants m'ont toujours connus et
reconnus handicapés puisque j'ai eu ça à
23 ans mes enfants 22 23 donc donc m ont
toujours connu
elles ont toujours connu handicapés et
un jour adolescente on était en mai la
table et elles me disent ah bah c'est
nul d'avoir qu'un seul droit parce qu'en
fait mes enfants y
ils ont au départ un petit peu jeune l
oms ça leur faisait bizarre que les gens
me regardent
effectivement c'est un peu gênant quand
on regarde son papa parce qu'il est
différent
bon ça a changé après elles ont vite
elles ont vite a accueilli la bonne
nouvelle que leur papa était handicapé
mais ça c'est bien
applicable les enfants c'est génial les
enfants un jour il ya un enfant qui est
né noir qui m'a dit tu t'es fait manger
tombera par un crocodile
c'est mignon sinon j'adore j'adore ou
alors vous savez le l'image de à la
plage pour moi quand je fais la plage
bien sûr ça se voit jamais le bain donc
ça doit vraiment bien mettre mon
handicap est en fait vous savez le
l'image du livre de l'enfant qui vous
revient comme ça qui quels comme ça et
que le cornet de glace il tombe
mes amis quand quand ils m'ont connu
bien sûr ils m'ont connu avec avec mon
handicap
mais depuis ils oublient quoi les oublie
par exemple quand il ya un déménagement
par exemple l'a deviné je fais pas je
fais partie de la liste des déménageurs
mois et ouais bon olivier tu porteras
les cartons un stéphane n'est pas un
truc away à tanger j'ai oublié j'ai
oublié c'est génial ça c'est génial
c'est que ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
voilà ça c'est ça c'est quelque chose de
ça quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup
alors par exemple bon moi je ne fais pas
mes lacets je fais pas mes chaussures je
fais pas mes chronos de cravate mais de
travail c'est pas grave la mode c'est
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça un petit
chemise avec un blazer voilà beau gosse
le macho mais mes lacets baléa sais
c'est pas grave si ma femme et mes
enfants sont pas là le matin c'est pas
grave je je je rentre je vais au travail
je mets mes lacets de mes chaussures et
puis je vais au travail
et là je fais faire mais lassé par mes
collègues
donc bon je demande à mes collègues donc
je présente le premier pied et puis mon
collègue il me fait me lasser et puis
s'en va je suis non un bras et de pied
tu as toi que donc il revient à la barre
m excuse ne t'inquiète pas ne t'inquiète
pas il ya un truc dans la vie qui est
terrible ce qui est extraordinaire qui
est terrible extraordinaire c'est que
quand mes enfants étaient tout petit
pour leur changer la couche mais elle
bougeait pas la vie est bien faite je
pense que la maison les enfants
en fait ils se rendent compte que leurs
parents et sont handicapés s'ils le sont
et elle bouge et les enfants bougent pas
quand c'était de nouveau une autre
personne à ça
mais moi ça bougeait pas ah par contre
ça m'a pas empêché de me faire pipi
dessus non ça c'est le handicap
n'empêche pas de se faire pipi dessus
donc ça c'est sûr ça marche pas voilà et
etc c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire du
handicap bon alors la vie on la connaît
elle est injuste ça serait c était juste
bon moi je suis chauvin donc
donc en fait vous faites là la vie de la
vie de personnes qui appellent pas
toujours facile des fois ça se passe
bien des fois ça se passe pas bien
alors moi ce que je voudrais vous faire
passer comme message c'est que c'est que
quand vous rencontrez une personne
handicapée faut pas hésiter à demander
si elle a besoin de l'aide
et si jamais elle n'a pas besoin d'aidé
vous le dira mais en tout cas à ce qui
est bien c'est qu'on peut faire des
choses ensemble et ça c'est ça permet de
de partage et de partager les choses ça
c'est ça c'est intéressant
effectivement il ya un souci
la langue française j'ai un petit soucis
mélenchon langue française
je vais me laver les mains à ya un truc
qui va pas là par contre si je vous dis
je vais me laver la main ouais c'est
moche ouais il connaît qu'à moi il ya
quelques temps et vient me voir et me
dit olivier j'ai amené ma voiture à
réparer au garagiste quand je suis
retourné pour payer la facture
ça m'a coûté un bras
la semaine d'après j'ai vendu ma voiture
et puis par exemple comme vous quand je
suis au spectacle c'est pas facile
l'applaudir bon alors je fais je fais ça
mais ça sert à rien c'est inutile sait
rien ou alors je prends la main de mon
voisin un quand vous êtes retourné je
prends la main de mon voisin je tape ou
alors ou alors ou alors ce que je fais
d'habitude ce que je fais ça je suis un
peu de bruit pour ça fait un peu peur
pour le lapin mais vont ces pratiques
c'est pratique je fais du bruit
voilà moi ce que j'aimerais vous vous
faire passer c'est que dans votre vie
dès que vous le pouvez
dès que vous pouvez mettez de la couleur
dans votre vie et manger du chocolat
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]